alive time to get to
work have a late start
today streamed pretty late last night
and then just crashed but we're good now
and uh you can't take a morning off it
seems
because the field will do
stuff we've got this awesome SIM from
from Eugene's lab to look
at GPU Drive GPU accelerated
2.5d multi agent driving Sim over a
million
FPS this looks very nice so I think what
we're going to try to do today is we're
going to see if we can make this
thing oh there's the stream we're going
to see if we can make this thing work
with puffer
Leb let's get started
don't need
this and I will also say that overnight
we had some nice
progress just before you get started on
GPU drive here we did have some very
nice progress overnight uh with some of
these training runs you can see cubert
takes a little longer for cubert to get
started it looks like but uh no we we do
have some decent runs here this is a the
good one up
here and uh we have I think beam rider
was really good
and beam Rider is really
good and I just I haven't even seen this
one yet this one is halfway done on
Space Invaders I
think yeah halfway done on Space
that you can see the
trend very
nice okay let's do um
oops let's do this
properly where's Eugene's
thing where's a
GitHub here it
is GPU
Drive 3 hours ago that means we're three
hours
late ippo perfect that's what we
have and O they don't have a package
guys you really need to have a a pip
package for this if you
package oh do they
have
H okay well we'll start with we'll start
from here
uh do I want to do this
local or do I want to do this on puffer
box I should do this local just in
case unless we lose conductivity or
something
uh
Docker let's get into our container
didn't finish watching last stream
watching from Europe
welcome you're not obligated to watch
all of the
streams um there's you know there's
always new stuff have you succeeded with
the ELO we have a nice implementation I
need to probably add some policies to it
but I'm pretty happy with how the
implementation is looking out looking
we're doing something different today
because there's this awesome release
from Eugene's lab they have a really
fast driving Sim I was actually tempted
to make one of these but it looks like
he's gone ahead and done
it this lab so we're going to see if we
can get Day One support and puffer I
hope we should be able to
do thing could use some squash commits
and maybe a pit
package let's see data
set simulator
gym
M perfect they just have a gym a gym
wrapper I don't know how it's a gy m
though if it's gy is not
multi-agent so we'll see how that
works and um from
there we have stuff to
do soon as this finishes
cloning stuck oh yeah there we
go
um oh right it's got uh it's got sub
modules on
it but yeah I see the stream is warming
up so uh for the YouTube folks today
what we're doing is we are adding
bindings for this awesome driving Sim
apparently it's very fast and uh my goal
is going to be to get this working which
is going to be the tough part I don't
know what like what stuff is under the
hood with this and then I think the easy
part is just going to be making this
thing stupidly fast and puffer I bet we
can beat whatever whatever thing they
have on this um speed wise if the
question is going to be how fast it runs
on CPU because the goal is if it runs at
like a million on
GPU um and we're trying to train it a
million steps per second that's half of
your time gone so if I run this on the
CPU cores and get the data to GPU fast
then potentially I can do way better
which would be really really
funny but I've seen it happen
before I'm a little bit concerned about
the API compatibility stuff
because they say it's a gy EnV but it
can't possibly be a gym because it's
multi-agent we'll do some fun stuff with
this so we have uh we've got this thing
now GPU
drive and what do they say how do we
install
this kind
of Linux and Mac
OS this is not bad
C++ was with the madona engine Madrona
is like this GPU game engine type thing
GPU environment
engine which is kind of funny because
I'm pretty sure with puffer you're no
longer going to need to implement M's
for GPU it's perfectly fine if they are
GPU but we can make it fast either way
there we
go okay so this is just setting up
madona
Twitter why can't I find uh Twitter for
this
set jeez you have to type this much in
order to get the name to show that's
ridiculous
it's pretty awesome what we've had with
puffer just while this is yeah 757
that's
crazy
okay so we have this built now
apparently is there a
the fact that I do not have pest
installed oh I do have
it does it not
work well probably this is good
right okay so it
supports there's human data as well
which I don't think we're going to play
too much with because we're just going
to do IPO to start
um and we're going to try to make that
stupidly
import okay there's quite a bit of stuff
here
um torch and Jack gymnasium interface
with the
simulator I'm a bit confused how they do
that because it's single
agent make EnV
you pass it a bunch of
configs and then agents this is probably
like a gymnasium VEC interface then
maybe uh episode with n parallel
environments okay this is not that bad I
think we can get this working pretty
quick let me start by making a
standalone and then we'll add a We'll
add this as a binding
is this going to work from here if this
is not uh as a pit
package oh they do this I see they they
actually have to do yeah that's slightly
a pain we'll have to
move are we going to do
this I think this was the case for
nocturn too I'd really suggest if you
guys can get a pit package together um
otherwise I'll just I'll just have to
set the paths or something it's not that
bad
so uh puffer play your streams while
working hard to find any valuable Dev
content everything is web or Game Dev
great for somewhere not in the field to
go at gra over yeah I mean hi I'm glad
it's uh glad it's
useful this is kind of Game Dev except
that the games are for reinforcement
learning agents to play
uh working
dur if
race this one goes up
here and then yeah we're
good okay that's that code
sample we'll get this GIF I don't think
this will work because we're on WSL
but okay that definitely did not
see and this display function where does
this come
from I don't see this dis
play
Anywhere okay so they have some
constants and put these up
environments GPU Drive gy M class and
base M torch M and Jacks
m one exports torch tensors in the other
Jacks array
so neither so this is not actually
gymnasium API it's just gymnasium like
API and we're going to have to rrap it
which is mildly obnoxious because we
actually have to get the data out of
from numai and then back into torch but
whatever that's
fine um so we have scene config
oops this actually gives us the action
space doesn't
it yeah there's going to have to be some
wrapper stuff going on um this is not
exactly a gem
interface and then render config
this is the
environment they do torch by default
that is a good
sign no more
M's really wish I knew why copy paste is
this
screwy but
whatever not a big
deal and perfect we can actually we're
not going to need this display function
I don't
think we can save this here
though uh we can actually
90 confused as to whether this is doing
anything
okay let's see where it's it's stopping
cuz something is it's getting hung up
somewhere
yeah it's
funny set working directory to the base
directory GPU Drive
GPU
um do I want to change the working
directory or do I want to sim link it
I always forget what order it
is yeah it's
Len okay perfect should not need to set
the working directory
GPU GPU Drive okay so this
works uh so I think it's
okay maybe this
works just Sim linking to
it 9
s o no module GPU Drive okay so this
thing is really not designed to work um
in a different directory
which is mildly mildly
annoying that's okay
though oops let's go back
to okay let's see what do
we what do we think we
are puffer tank SL GPU Drive
do you need to have like the Poetry
install or something is there a setup.py
there is a setup.py that we didn't run
right oh wait
no what about the
toml is this thing installed correctly
weird okay I think there's something
wrong with the build we definitely need
to get this working without this like
path shenanigans is
toml tool.
Poetry ah it actually does have to be
poetry
they have the tool it tooled for
poetry they have the tool it tooled for that that's where the uh the missing
that that's where the uh the missing
file was all right my bad for wanting to
use my own
tools I just did it
again just reflexively
why is it adding Cuda
packages I already have those
I don't think that this works you can't
just
make the package because it doesn't give
you the links
it says that you should be able to do
this so this was supposed to work and it
didn't that's
these this is always the bothersome and
boring part right is getting the thing
actually installed
correctly um and then hopefully I'm
hopeful that this should be fairly quick
after that to get running and then get
integrated with puffer it's going to
depend how heavily they
um they different they uh well how much
they diverge from the gymnasium API
because it's not they say they have a
gymnasium interface but it's not quite a
gymnasium
interface I assume that they mean they
have like a torch tensor GP uh torch
tensor gymnasium VC interface so if
that's the case then I'm going to have
to take their interface I'm going to
have to wrap it with puffer get those
into numpy
Rays on
CPU and see how fast I can get it
running multicore
this thing not done
oh it is it's just like did something
weird we'll see if it works with poetry
I'm hoping it works with just this this
manual install should be
better but I was getting
um I was getting like a link error with
this it didn't link the package
correctly
let me see in the meantime if I can
figure out how this
yeah stream will be back up if it's
still on as soon as this blip is
that's wait the stream looks like it's
still
alive so hold on I think that it's just
is it just that poetry is eating all my
bandwidth is that what H what's
happening let me check on my phone if
the internet's
fine and I see the stream still being up
here so I'm going to get this I'm going
to give this a second to finish
downloading and hopefully then it stops
eating all my
bandwidth it's the last time I triy
poetry for anything though
so will these
load
yeah okay this actually doesn't look too
bad to get set up once we're uh once
we're ready and they they have actually
they have good versions of everything as
well these are the versions that puffer
uses as well these are just the latest
versions of everything so we should be
fine so I'll wait for a torch to finish
downloading I think that literally all
that happened is that this just uh
poetry just ate all of our bandwidth and
took the stream down for a second it
looks like we're good
now so welcome back folks
we're going to give it a second to
finish torch I think it just did like
some crazy multi-threaded download and
just took the like took all the
bandwidth so I'll go over my plan while
I'm waiting for this um it looks to me
that they have a they have a uh
multimodal action space or multi- a
structured action space I should
say I think one of the tutorials had
what it was I hope it's not mixed
discreet and
continuous let me
see what environment this is GPU Drive
was just launched today
by where the heck did it
lab and we're going to try to make it
very very
have it looks to me like they have um
continuous steering and
acceleration which is pretty easy for us
to handle and
puffer haven't done much with the
continuous
environments je
okay can we
work cannot open shared object file I
see it right here don't I buffer Li GPU
Drive
build GPU drive. cpython
do oh
that's
weird it built it with
on include cpython 311 but I have python
okay let me try this make let me try the
make version again the from
Source they do have python 311 pinned
here
oops it's crazy that they actually made
this thing build on Windows
let me make this work first and then I
think if I just do
error cre created
wheel stored in directory
311 and it clearly is right here it's
generating for some
reason I don't know why it would be
generating like this though why was it
generating with 310
could not
[Music]
how do I run Madrona in CPU mode because
I want to do that
oh look at that we got it
running not
him we're going to get them lots of nice
stuff on this today
welcome but this
works
right you can see we have the car it
runs it does stuff
right new to
python well this is going to be a bit
much then we are doing uh high
performance reinforcement learning
development today a new GPU accelerated
driving simulator released from uh some
buddies of mine at
NYU and they are doing uh it looks very
good so I'm adding a binding to puffer
lib so we can train neural networks to
drive cars
fast or
well yeah this is the environment we're
playing with right
now to GPU driving end these are
cars uh just started on porting
this but yeah that's the plan for
today so first thing I want to figure
here 10 by 128 that is
weird this is nice what libraries my
main stuff is in puffer
here put it in the
chat open source high performance
reinforcement
learning try to make everything very
simple as
Ah that's
why so is this 128 per
[Music]
scene oh it's because yeah yeah so
there's this scene is
large right num
worlds so 10
worlds up
to 128 objects
tell how I should be looking at
this I don't know if I do this if I do
one is it going to be totally
different is this going to be a
different
map but I only see one
car right I and I I guess it's like
vaults if you don't close it properly
but I only see one car
here which just
disappeared
H I'm not sure how to
well let's not abuse This Thread I'll
tweet
what I understand you're simulating cars
and trying to B find the best path for
it to move something like that this is
not my environment this is just released
today by NYU what I'm trying to do is
I'm trying to add support for this into
puffer lib so we can train RL to do
probably what you just said uh at very
well we can do that very fast and easy
that's the
goal video frames per second is four I
cannot test how fast this is as is
though was
annoying we'll be able to do that later
I think for
now basically what Tesla a i
does sort
of much smaller
scale but yeah kind of I believe you can
do it better man if you want me to do a
test does bit better I'll uh please give
me my pick of like a th Engineers from
like a the Thousand best Engineers I
want and like several billion dollars
and then we'll
talk you can't compete with that number
of resources at this
scale okay you want to see how funny
that is actually this is so
Tesla do I have a picture of
it yeah okay
so this is what their data centers look
like this is what my data center looks
like little bit of a
difference little bit of a
difference all right so I think that we
can actually start adding this to puffer
already um there are a few things that
are bothering me here let's make a
little
wrapper they have a I don't know how
many billions of dollar cluster I have a
$30,000 cluster
where did you learn
python I think I learned python when I
was like 16 by porting one of my crappy
neural networks from mat lab so I don't
you just start writing code and you keep
writing code until the code stops
looking
bad oh then you're starting at a good
age that's when I started doing research
this actually should not be a rapper
right this needs to
be yeah all this stuff needs to go into
the
class I don't know if you're new to all
this stuff and you want to do some cool
stuff in AI or whatnot I would just it's
going to take a lot of time so be
patient and also so just like start
writing code and don't get too wrapped
up in like doing fancy objectoriented
crap or fancy functional crap just like
write simple code that that makes cool
projects all
so now we have self.
M
um I want to take a look at the
observation spaces
here what just
happened
S.M class values must be non- negative
what's GPU Drive should I just put this
up on the side of the stream so that
people can see
it I'm just going to like put Eugene's
post up on this screen okay this is GPU
drive this is I don't have enough screen
space for it um but yeah this is GPU
Drive they have fancy driving Sim
I have time done cool projects with some
help classes suck because yeah classes
suck oh well no I I thought you meant
like instructional classes like lectures
but yes those whatever Noah this is
supposedly a million step per second
environment we're going to see how much
better we can do it's a GPU environment
my plan is to run it on CPU m mul core
with puffer so that we don't waste the
GPU time on the m and we use all the GPU
time for the
network since we've got like a newer
person to stuff here I'm just going to
make one small detour
comment if you just want to see like how
far you can go in 10 years um this is
some of my like absolute garbage work
from when I was
16 I think I'm 16 in this
photo this is like me training really
really bad like neural networks on
convet or
pounds
um yeah there's like some neural network
stuff in
here but yeah this is some of the stuff
I built when I was way
time how many SPS are you hoping to get
out of it I don't know we're going to
see how long it takes more than what
they currently have whatever they have
at the moment I want to do I want to get
it to be faster than they have it
here I literally just pasted this into
the class and now no longer
yeah no
worries did you call the
class yeah you'll see I mean if you're
just hang around you'll see some
Dev
okay so it actually it does have a
proper observation space on it um but I
don't think it's the correct observation
space
this you see right here that this is not
what was get
given they say it has 30 oh wait no is
this
right it's not exactly
right because they stacked it
weird this needs to be
reshaped this needs to be
reshaped and what do they have for
Action
space discreet of nine
really discreet of
nine that doesn't look right does
it steer
actions we using Panda no there's no
pandas so this is reinforcement learning
this means that uh the data comes from a
simulator this data is generated in
memory by interacting with the simulator
so you do not need any tools for
interacting with large data sets what
you need is you need ultra high
performance ways of getting gigabytes of
data per second from multiple CPU cores
onto the GPU or you need ultra high
performance ways of you know generally
coupling this back and forth simulator
runs simulation simulator returns data
neuron net acts on data neuronet returns
actions to simulator simulator steps
forward that's the that is the loop that
needs to run fast
I have no clue about what you just said
good it would be kind of weird if you
did I'd be very
impressed I would be very impressed if
you did
if you're trying to pick up machine
learning though I would highly suggest
yeah I will repeat that slower since
other people are confused as well but um
if you're trying to learn AI stuff I
would highly recommend cs231n the
lectures are online Stanford course it's
a grad course but it's a very accessible
grad course that's where I would start
yes let me repeat
so the way that this works in
reinforcement learning right
reinforcement learning is not like
supervised learning we don't have a big
data file with 10 terab of data that we
then need to load off of the dis and
like manage and get into the neural
network that's not what we're doing what
we instead have is a simulator it's like
a game in this case it's not a game it's
a driving Sim but same thing and what
we're going to do is we're going to run
many copies of this simulator on
different CPU cores okay and they're all
going to run at the same time so what we
need is we need a really fast way of
getting all that data from all those
different cores to the GPU they have to
get onto the main process and then they
get onto the GPU that's a lot of data
that has to be processed very very fast
we're talking like you have a few
microsc that you can waste here um but
it has to be very efficient overall and
then that data once it's on the GPU is
run through a neural network the neural
network tells all the cars what to do
where to steer how to accelerate so on
and so forth that data gets sent back to
all all the different
processes and then the simulators step
forward using that information they say
okay the car is going to go this way and
then they return more data that process
has to be very fast that is what puffer
lib
does hi is it possible to create a
Starcraft 2 AI like Alpha star using the
reinforcement learning resources you
have um the closest thing I have for you
for that is on my Twitter the main
project I was building at the uh one of
the main projects I'm building at the
GIF we've got a MOA it's uh not not
Alpha star it's closer to DOTA but I've
been building this this runs it like a
million steps per second per core so we
can actually train this with the
resources I have we're not going to be
able to train on like Starcraft properly
just because the game is too slow but
you could very easily do a project well
not EAS easily but with the about the
same amount of effort I could have done
like an RTS instead of a MOA and had
something like this as
well at what point did you get into
RL in your ml
Journey practice it so RL is I've worked
in Vision I've worked in natural
language processing I did both of those
for about three years reinforcement
learning is much much harder not from a
math perspective not from a research
perspective necessarily but from a pure
engineering perspective because you have
this giant additional stack of tools
that has to work with complex
simulators so 80% of my work is
engineering building this type of stuff
um that is what makes it hard but you
still have to know all the other stuff
in ml now the nice thing is that I'm
fixing this uh I've only been on this
now for three months since I graduated
my PhD I've been doing reinforcement
learning for like seven years but this
is where I finished my PhD and started
working on puffer lip full-time this has
been the growth on the project in the
last couple two three months so we are
very very quickly making reinforcement
learning fast simple and
easy also much harder in
theory I say I think it's harder than
everything in supervised learning except
for the uh the infra Engineers who have
to do the multi- noode uh the multi-
node scaling on like large language
models the multimachine scaling
infrastructure is probably as hard or
harder than this but everything else
hard the nice thing is we do kind of
have unlimited data so we don't have to
worry about overfitting and
regularization and stuff as
much that's nice but uh we have every
other problem in the
book okay let me figure out why the heck
this thing wasn't
working oh you are actually right I
forgot to instantiate the class before
that's
funny I wasn't paying attention
is
reset this is
fine match API death step with
action and we'll see what this
returns I don't know if it has a step
function
does was not really until
RL that you started going hard into the
engineering
aspect I mean this the engineering side
has been relatively recent I did a lot
of simulation development for neural MMO
that involved a fair bit of like
engineering and components and stuff but
uh the ultra high performance RL is
something that has happened since I
graduated because it's not something
that you can really work on well in
Academia um so this is a relatively
recent thing that said it's been going
incredibly well like in three months we
have simulations that are 100 times
faster than everything else
mhm it's funny cuz I never really liked
um I never really liked low-l
engineering when I was in college or
whatever and I still don't but the only
reason I don't is because of fiddly
tools that make it impossible to debug
stuff with the current stack of stuff I
have on puffer it's pretty painless I
can just like write super fast stuff
right cuz obviously like I know how to
do all of it right it's just a matter of
having an interface for it that doesn't
suck
we do all sorts of stuff for
um for the simulation code in puffer
though we do
like they are zero dynamic memory
accesses we have like all the memory
pre-allocated for The Sims we do
occasionally we'll do stuff like um like
flat circular buffers so that to avoid
copying data around we do a lot of like
memory views between Python and syon so
we have zero uh zero copies that way
we'll do stuff like we'll simulate
everything inside of shared memory so
that you actually don't even have to
like copy the data around to get it off
onto the main
process lots and lots of big
optimizations is that why you use syon
yes syon is awesome do you do the
simulations in puffer puffer has some
first party simulations um um that I
have made and it also has uh
optimizations for other environments as
well some depending on how fast your
environment is like generally the faster
your environment is the faster puffer
can make it if that makes sense like if
your environment is slow then there's
like really not anything to optimize
because it's really easy to handle tiny
amounts of data but as your environment
gets faster puffer makes it even faster
so there's a compounding effect
like it's going to be very very soon
that the standard for reinforcement
learning is your M has to run it a
million steps per second and they're
going to be lots of M that run at a
million steps per second and training is
going to be at hundreds of thousands to
a million steps per second as well all
because of
puffer and a few other Niche groups as
well that are like doing cool stuff like
this group here at NYU is awesome
um this needs a bunch of API garbage
doesn't
it what does poer do to speed the end up
so much
vectorization most
environments it it's very hard to get
let's say your environment runs at a
th000 steps per second right or no more
than that let's say it runs at like 5
6,000 steps per second right and you
have 16 cores like the default
vectorization will run at like 10,000
steps per second that's what the rest of
the field will use you get absolutely
ter absolutely terrible scaling puffer
gives you good
scaling if it gives you a lot more on
top of that but that's one of our killer
features is like really really good
H oh that's
weird that's fine
though we'll just do like this
okay didn't know this sort of computing
wasn't vectorized oh well they tried to
but they do it very
slowly I tried running demo. Pi with the
forging of in profile mode but I got an
error do I have to do additional stuff
um I might just have a bug in it if you
paste the error no I can debug it for
you real
quick nice so we got uh we got this
running the puffer
wrapper and we have to
do death
render he world
compiled well then it doesn't do
anything reu but like that's not going
to be the case ever for every thing like
you have to write your entire Sim to be
GPU which like okay look they have
they've made this thing for GPU but how
much work do you think this took to do
on GPU like how much less work do you
think this would be if I wrote it for
CPU right it's like a tenth of the
complexity to do stuff for just CPU um
like if I were trying to write the MOBA
for GPU I'd be doing that for months
months and months and
months and also gpus are just not good
in general at doing arbitrary logic like
that's what CPUs are for right gpus are
good for lots of dumb syy parallel
operations so it's way smarter in my
opinion to just bet on Sims having to be
uh most Sims being on CPU and making
that really fast like the reason that
people came up with these fancy GPU Sim
Frameworks in the first place is cu how
stupidly slow it was on CPU not because
CPUs are slow but because the code stack
was bad
is let me fix that for you real quick
Noah
think people moved M to GPU because GPU
is like having a lot of
CPUs it's not though do you know the
restrictions behind GP like have you
looked at like the Jack scan operations
for instance it executes all possible
branches of your code at every step it's
really hard to write arbitrary code on
that
this it probably just didn't compile the
snake and
runs there there you go Noah I just uh
I'd forgotten something in the port so
the way that that that function works
like you have to set it for like a short
train run and then you'll get stats on
that train run I would generally suggest
that you probably want to profile the
envit self not the entire train Loop and
there's like their little profiling
Snippets in most of the M's that you can
use for
that Jack me vmap with conditionals also
yeah that's what I mean
JBL it's really
janky most of the time it's like why
would I spend so much effort getting
something to run a million steps per
second on a GPU which is the big
expensive piece right when I can make it
run easily a million steps per second on
one CPU
core right it's like oh no the
infrastructure is so hard in order to
get that data onto the GPU efficiently
yeah but puffer doesn't and our whole
stack for doing that is a thousand
lines just nobody bothered to do this
right
puffer does it now it
um now we have to make this puffer
environment
compatible so what we're going to do is
how do you get one mil steps per second
on a single CPU core very easily just by
not writing an optimized garbage python
like any of the you can look at the
source code of any of my environments
they're very simple they're single file
cython they're just single file of
cython uh it runs pure C but it's a lot
easier than writing pure
C I'm pretty confident at this point
that I can Implement practically any
environment out there like any type of
game EnV I want I can make like a
reasonable version of at several hundred
thousand steps per second guaranteed a
million steps per second probably and in
many cases many millions of steps per
second per
core like I don't know I was playing
slay the Spire the other day I could
make that game run a million steps per
second if I just implemented it like
this right do it for whatever I want
flow what about
robotics yeah if you need a physics Sim
that's the that is the actual use case
for gpus is if you need an expensive
physics Sim pretty much everything else
though
nah so that is with no paralyzation yeah
you can get a million steps per second
without any
paraliz it depends what you mean by
parallelization if you mean multicore
yeah without multicore just one thread
you can do that I do end up running
multiple copies of the environment per
core um for convenience but I can still
get it to be pretty darn close to that
even without it in fact you know if you
just get rid of the the loop overhead
from python you still get a million per
second nothing fancy really there's
nothing to it and go read like The Snake
code or the MOBA code there's nothing
crazy in
need to get these OBS into a reasonable
format
right class values must be non-
negative what did I
are you not allowed to put a break point
there you should be
right well there we go it's fine
OBS
NP
reshape num
worlds
times objects
work
nice so is there there is significant
performance increase with puffer just
running one copy of an environment
okay you're you're conflating two things
here right there are puffer's first
party environments which are the
environments that I've written to be
fast right those environments are going
to be fast uh on their own but then if
you try to run those vectorized with
other vectorization like Jim's
vectorization that's going to be slow
cuz their vectorization implementation
is bad so in order to have many copies
of the environment on many cores be even
faster you need puffer Libs
vectorization so in a way puffer Libs ve
enables puffer Libs environments now if
you just hand me any old arbitrary
environment that's slow to begin with
garbage and garbage out I can't make
something that slow any faster but if
let's say you have a reasonably fast
environment that's being bottlenecked by
Jim's really stupidly slow vectorization
then yes puffer's vectorization will
make it
faster the limiting factor is python
itself well yeah python a slow language
right you can't just write a you can't
write a simulation in pure Python and
expect it to be fast like many of the um
many of the simulations that researchers
use are just garbage unoptimized Python
and it runs it like a few hundred steps
per second like I can't do anything with
that right the easiest way for me to fix
something like that is to throw the
environment away and rewrite it in scyon
and then it'll be a million steps per
second this one here is an exception
which is why I'm using it right this is
a really fast one on
works
mpai mpai
tensors it should not be done on step
one that's really weird
nice okay so this is actually getting
pretty close to being usable already
believe it or
not I'm sure there's a little bit of API
Shenanigans we've
forgotten um but this now
returns we need numb agents right
yeah self. Nom
agents I want this the other way
around all
right and then we'll do like
this
agents I'm surprised that there's no
infos returned by this
tensor this actually uh is it a discret
action space am I reading this
right guess so kind of weird I'll ask
him if that's intentional but
so here is our uh here's our
code don't really need this display gift
function I'll just put this down here
for
now where do I put
this n
whatever
um let's grab all this
code and
let's there
GPU
Drive um what are we going to copy for
Drive okay so this is just code that we
copied from
garbage this is just from uh these are
all the first party M code I just copied
this as a template
Creator and this can
return I think this just can return the
fun this can just return
puffer CPU Drive right just be a
here I don't know if we need this worked
or anything I hope we don't need this
anymore um we will put these constants
down here whichever ones we're actually
going to use at
least not
used the name
not
used unique yeah this is used and these
other ones are used
right we might need episode
length we do not need
this we do not need
this
TCH
um we do need torch which is a little
bit obnoxious
and we need puffer of
course everything is better with
okay so we have M crator puffer CPU
drive and now we have to add a binding
to puffer
lib what is wrong why can't I type
we go
um copy
config uh
ocean what we say we copy like the snake
okay we have some stuff in here
right GPU
Drive GPU
drive now we have a config for
it uh is that it
data does not exist or is empty so I
assume that we need this annoying um
this
changer that's a little bit
silly
no
dim actions is not
ah it is
in 73
right this has to be a torch tensor is
slightly
annoying doesn't need to be put to GPU
puffer is a CPU library for
shape
what did we say the uh
hold
on what's the shape of the reaction
here num worlds Max num objects okay so
we do actually have to reshape
it slightly annoying no big
deal so that is an in the the thing
itself come
on GPU drive
error LOL it
works
haha apparently this thing is
running cool didn't expect it to run
that quickly
let's go look at their networks and like
add a reasonable Network and then we'll
do optimizations and make this thing
real
concerning but we'll
see re
that's so funny that Eugene actually
like manages the bug issues and like
assigns grad students to stuff that's so
network policy
actor agents policy
actor do you have documentation of all
the outof thebox
optimizations if I want to write my own
M inside python um the way to think
about it is that just puffer's
vectorization is really really fast so
it's not going to cap your speed of your
environments to be way lower than it
should be if you want a like a
comparison or you want convincing yes
there's a white
paper there's like a good page here of
optimizations and there's also uh there
are some perf tests on on stuff the perf
actually has gotten way better since
then because like I literally the
environments weren't even fast enough
for me to show how good puffer is if
that makes sense because when you get
really fast environments that's when you
really start to see existing
vectorization implementations just
chug I guess I we kind of did right we
had like 4 million versus
100,000 that's like a good
example yeah they just chug
okay we're going to look for their
agents in
gigantic
wait
huh where's your network
demo oh there was a DOT High I'm just
dumb oh no they didn't have it up there
okay um
where but
like policy
actor I'm so confused
saved model trained policy
path model learned
sp3 where's your
implementation oh it's freaking
sb3 oh that's hilarious wait if this is
sb3 then I'm going to be way faster are
you planning on implementing any GPU
acceleration the thing is you don't need
any of this if you have GPU acceleration
like you don't need parallelization and
stuff cuz all you're in for it is fast
and it's easy right like the thing is
that you just you put all the difficulty
into writing the Sim um it depends how
complicated your physics are though
right like we have stuff with continuous
control now uh if you have really heavy
physics then yeah you're probably going
to want to keep it there but if you're
just like if you have some like light
physics stuff and it's not super fine
grained like it doesn't run jillion
times per second then uh you can
probably just do a CPU and and have it
be faster with puffer you got to
remember that your network is supposed
to train on the GPU so anytime you're
running the environment on the GPU is
time that you're stealing from your
policy right so if your environment runs
a million steps per second well you're
not going to train more than like
500,000 steps per second right cuz your
Network's going to take a m your
Network's going to take half the time
and your environment's going to take
half the
time and buffer is just going to keep
getting faster as well we have um we
have like optimizations more and more
optimizations coming for CPU stuff so
like ultimately it's just going to be I
I think that this just
wins doesn't mean that environments like
this aren't useful though because I can
just run this in CPU mode and it's still
going to be fast um and you know if you
want to not deal with puffer's whole
stack of stuff and you want a really
really simple thing then yeah you know
you can just run it in GPU
mode but I think it's going to be less
and less necessary to have to suffer so
much in order to get this level of speed
that said this specific project is
really really good work I'm excited to
make it even faster for them
see thanks bro yeah no
worries we're having good times with
this if you haven't already go ahead and
give puffer a star if you find any of
this useful helps me out a whole
ton we're at 758 right now huge amounts
of progress
where is their
thingy and has Eugene replied to
me oh dapne
did Max cont agents
determines maximum you want to
control since number of different
vehicles can be controlled 10 may result
in you controlling five agents in one
and nine and another up to at most
ooh that might be a tough
one that might be a tough
you if you're not doing proper masking
that's going to create problems s
luckily puffer does have a masking
feature but we might have to do some
modification of
stuff in order to make this go Zoom
right s
sp3 yeah this is painful having to do
this with SP
sp3 where is
their MLP class
policy
is exp
config where's exp
config ipo.
config late Fusion net and late Fusion
policy networks perm
EQ all
right down the rabbit hole looking for
this
aha perm EQ late
Fusion what is a late Fusion
architecture am I just
dumb have I just am I just dumb for not
having heard of
what is this something really obvious
and like really common that I've just
never heard
of fusion of different modalities no
that's something different all right
let's read the
o
yikes they got a lot of
stuff doesn't look they got like they
have anything fancy outside of that
though
I'm afraid this network is just going to
be
slow the main problem
oh
wait up to at most 10
puffer fish
go puffer fish
go absolutely puffer fish
Moon build out network is they do linear
layer Norm
Dropout linear layer
Norm I do not believe that that is a
good
policy I have to read their paper for
ablations but I do not believe that is a
good
policy long time everything yep doing
well lots of progress being made here
we're currently adding bindings
for this where is it
where's this
thing this awesome GPU driving Sim
adding this to puffer lib and we're
going to see if we can make it really
fast I'm trying to figure out how much
of this I actually
want
G I think that um
ego State Road objects Road graph
right I think this is like this the
stuff that I
want let's start copying this stuff in
though to the uh the model not going to
get anywhere
by m
around do we use the snake M to
start we'll use
this
policy your work and personal of firing
hey I'm glad you find my stuff
interesting it is all really
available right here
good but Day One support for a Sim like
this is going to be real cool to
have they're going to be real cool to
have ego State
them I think what we really just care
about here and it's so funny to see them
do this because this is what you do with
the puffer Advanced API is you basically
do this exact thing and they've done it
for me but um I can tell that this
involved a lot of pain and suffering and
uh there is a much easier API in Puffer
that prevents pain and suffering that
would let you do the same thing so we'll
use their Advanced API and make it
really fast for them since they've gone
to the effort but uh you know much much
pain and suffering could have been
saved definitely much pain and suffering
could have been saved sa
D can we save me some pain and suffering
with this freaking terrible copy
paste
this the killer feature of vs code is
not like any anything that neovim
doesn't have it's being able to actually
copy and paste
so uh we have all these like config
thingies
where's their
config I think it's baselines
config yeah this thing right here
so
okay num worlds is going to be
50 we defin definitely want this
file it's pretty cool that they have
their lab is called emerge
lab that's
fun oh they even have hyper parameters
for us that's very nice of
them I really hope we just solve this
environment
today that'd be just so funny ah they
actually have a very tiny little
Network tiny tiny little Network look at
this tiny tiny little
dim I don't see where this thing is in
the config
is it's supposed to be
State they have a lot of stuff in here
don't
they oh that's so sad that they had to
write this in pi
game that must have been very
painful it's like so funny having just
been in this space for long enough that
like I know which packages just suck to
work with and like I can just look at
the code and just say oh they had to do
this with that man that must have been
you know several weeks of somebody's
life
o the goal is to get to a place where
those packages no longer exist and we
only have good packages so we can write
stuff like this without it being
painful uh ego State
baselines no it's where was it was in
networks build your own packages from
scratch I do build my own packages from
scratch all the time
I didn't like the Atari renderer
yesterday so I wrote one with
RB okay so ego input
dim anywhere we see ego input Dem this
is ego State
Dem and then this is row input
Dem so this
is partner
it road map oh this is road map agent
feet dim
personal pet peeve
but I do not like types in
Python I do not like typed
no typing and function signatures is
crazy man no no no let me tell you
what's crazy man what's crazy man is
having type
signatures uh typing in function
signatures that is not even enforced and
doesn't make your code any faster that's
what's
crazy when it's literally just there
telling you that this is the type and
that's not even necessarily the type
that's what's
crazy I like my types when they actually
make the code fast and actually do
something not when they sit around and
pretend to be
useful why do you need typescript I
already typed my script I type them with
a
keyboard it's for the readability n no
no there's you know what's readable
readable is how what's readable is when
there's less code because it's not
littered with types all right I don't
need to know that this is of type int
okay I see it says 32 that's the default
I don't need to know that this EnV is of
type like environment it's called EnV
we're
good I will gladly use types in syon
when it gives me a million frames per
second
not in Python where it does nothing
like is this useful I know this is a
torch tensor it's inside of a freaking
torch policy right I know it's going to
return a tensor because it's returning a
thing and it's a torch
do does this thing need a CNN anywhere I
don't think so
right we just need hidden size 128
maybe this is something we'll never see
ey on you can look at my scon code like
I use I it's like yeah it's it's typed
it's
fine honestly like the thing is if I
have to type my python code like it's
not even worth using python for me
anymore it's that bad like if I'm going
to be typing my code anyways I want them
enforced and I want to have speed out of
it like I I'll pick literally any other
language rather than type my python code
I'd rather just write the whole thing in
scyon at that
I will sometimes type the function
signatures for like uh documentation of
exposed stuff like if I have like a very
small surface of exposed code then
sometimes I'll do it so that the autod
do picks it up as well but uh anything
internal is not getting no it's not
getting
typed is not happening
you can't make
me now we have the non-deterministic
bug love me some non-deterministic
okay okay um well that's mildly
irritating
features I'm confused
used I don't think you need this I think
this is literally just a
Max Max across
objects well this isn't bad at
least yeah this is not bad at
so I think I just up with a little
Network for this
bed pop for a
lib
net oops
hidden
be 64
okay this is what we wanted so we just
have a linear REO
linear and then what we do is we do a
Max
I'd like to figure out how to do
Max I'd like to figure out how to do that well but we'll start with
that well but we'll start with
this and
then self.
rge is going to
be from 3 * the input size to the hidden
size figure me
that okay and then we
do
embed we're going to make this network
so
fast it's going to have memory it's
going to be awesome their network does
not have any memory by the way isn't
that funny the driving cars that have no
memory
values
indices okay
do no let's not do that let's just do it
this
on this one doesn't need
Max I don't think
right yeah no this one doesn't need it
that looks pretty good to
me that looks pretty
good what do we think we think this is
going to
train once we uh figure that's an
environment
bug come
on there it
goes oh
yeah we
train we' be
training solid
here RNN names got to be recurrent
Let's uh let's set some hyper parameters
yeah
so policy name is policy RNN name is
recurrent and we can use their
hypers they gave us some nice
99 G Lambda 0.9
5 clip
coefficient 2 value function coefficient
0.5 uh VF clip coefficient I think is
going to be the same
0.2 grad
Norm 0.5 will be a good default I don't
see
wait three e this is 4 e minus 3 did I
do it
backwards what was it 3 e minus 4 yeah
this num epox is
five are you guys sure about that that's
uh that's going to slow you down a
lot that's a bad sign right there I'm
leave it at one for
num
worlds stuff like
that
mhm so far so good
mini batch
size Let's uh do some
optimizing
384 okay can I figure out what the heck
is wrong with this
35,000 53% on the
N so we didn't even do multicore yet
10 I probably want 4096 per core right
so let me
think that's 32m
right seems like a
lot we'll try it for
now this is where we're going to have to
figure out that bug if we want to
continue because it's so unlikely that
we're going to get a good one
really that's a lot of
data it's a lot of data
I mean we'll see whether this ends up
being reasonable or not but that's a lot
of
data I bet this Sim is not going to end
up being crazy fast on
CPU I'm going to think if I'm going to
do like
24 24
instead let's let's do 1024 environments
instead so we'll divide this by four
we'll do eight
worlds this gives
and this
is let's do like
eight num workers is
eight do I have N8 core
it's m b size the pram
name okay so what I'm doing now is I'm
setting Hardware optimal
parameters okay that's good it's about
the same as what it was before
right okay so this is this bug that we
got to fix
right one hun in code
is also let's see if I have any other
replies from uh the creators of this
I might hop off the stream for a few
minutes here in order
to do
okay I'm going to hop off the stream for
a quick second to do a call I'll be back
in a
few oh
unless she is watching the live stream
I'm one of the
devs I'm going to close the stream I'll
be back in a few